nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction les contreforts de l'Himalaya
dans le nord de l'Inde dans la plus
haute chaîne de montagne du monde le
réchauffement climatique menace les
milliers de glaciers avec pour
conséquence de cette fonte accélérée des
catastrophes naturelles comme ils sont
produits de plus en plus régulièrement
éboulement de terrain avalanche ou
effondrement de glaciers Alban Alvarez
vous êtes notre correspondant en Inde et
vous nous emmener aujourd'hui dans le
petit état de l'outare acande
régulièrement victime de ses
catastrophes aggraver par une course
effrénée ou développement des
infrastructures
absolument Antoine et c'est même la que
réside le paradoxe de l'Inde le pays qui
dépend de du charbon pour produire 80%
de son électricité tente d'investir
massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables ces dernières années en
vue d'atteindre la neutralité carbone
ici 2070 New Delhi investit donc dans le
solaire mais surtout dans les centrales
hydro-électriques en Himalaya le
problème c'est que la construction est
bien de ces centrales fragilise une
région déjà menacée par le réchauffement
climatique alors on va découvrir ça avec
vous Alban Himalaya la bombe climatique
qui menace l'Inde star portage d'Alban
Alvarez et n'abody takumari pour France
[Musique]
nous étions en train de travailler dans
notre chambre près du pont ma belle-mère
et moi il me faisait beau on distinguait
pas un nuage dans le ciel et puis vers
9h30 levront a commencé à souffler
violemment dans un bruit assourdissant
[Musique]
et rapidement j'ai vu les arbres les
plantes être déracinées et une masse
emportée tout sur son passage on ne
voyait plus que des débris
imagine pas que son village reculé dans
les contreforts de l'Himalaya s'apprête
à changer de visage pour l'éternité
le 7 février 2021 un flanc du sommet de
la montagne rontie situé à 6000 mètres
d'altitude s'effondre formant un tsunami
de glace et de roche qui va parcourir 22
km et tout emporté sur son passage
[Musique]
la cascade debout déferle la plus de son
km/h bilan plus de 200 morts et disparus
[Musique]
parmi les victimes la belle-mère de
godam baryde vit qui travaillait dans
les champs près de la rivière et dont il
ne reste que cette falaise de gravats
en retournant les débris avec l'aide
d'un bulldozer en vain puis un jour un
chien a trouvé un morceau de sa tunique
noire et jaune c'est la vie traditionnel
que les femmes portent dans notre
communauté
depuis nous vivons dans la peur que cela
se répète
nous n'avions jamais vu cela de notre
vie
une partie de la montagne se détacher
puis tomber ça me hante tous les jours
[Musique]
dans sa course folle le toron a emporté
deux barrages hydrauliques et des
dizaines d'employés qui travaillaient
dessus
l'un d'eux est situé en contrebas du
village
deux ans après la catastrophe le
déblayage se poursuit dans des
conditions précaires
ces projets de barrage ne font pas
l'unanimité auprès des habitants depuis
plus de 10 ans à toute Saty un natif de
la région dénoncent leur construction
avant il y avait un pont
il a été pulvérisé
on se croirait dans une tranchée on
dirait qu'un bombardement a eu lieu
c'est le parfait exemple du conflit qui
oppose l'homme à la nature
conséquence du réchauffement climatique
deux tiers des 15000 glaciers que
contient Malaya sont menacé de
disparition une font accélérée par la
hausse des températures et qui pourrait
conduire à de nouvelles catastrophes
naturelles comme celle-ci selon de
nombreux scientifiques
l'Himalaya est une chaîne de montagnes
très fragile
et ses projets d'infrastructures vont
s'avérer être de plus en plus dangereux
dans le futur
les glaciers fondent et nos rivières ça
sèche
nous devrions plus tôt trouver des
solutions pour la préservation de l'eau
plutôt que de se lancer dans ces
immenses projets qui abîme davantage nos
montagnes
pourtant à quelques kilomètres de là
rien ne semble pouvoir arrêter la
reconstruction du barrage
hydroélectrique de tapovane
l'ouvrage a lui aussi était gravement
endommagé par la crue qui a suivi la
chute du glacier c'est ici que le bilan
humain était le plus lourd pour atout il
est devenu le symbole de cette course
effrénée au développement encouragé par
le gouvernement indien après
l'incarnation même de l'avidité des
autorités
profit de la nature autant qu'il le
souhaite
pour ce projet de centrale électrique
non seulement il construisent un barrage
mais ils sont en train de dévier le
cours de la rivière dans un tunnel sous
la montagne
c'est un désastre écologique au nom du
développement
le barrage de tabo Vannes est loin
d'être le seul projet du gouvernement
dans cette région pour répondre à des
besoins en électricité en constante
augmentation new délit entend faire de
l'outarracande le premier producteur
d'énergie hydroélectrique du pays
[Musique]
surplombé par 1400 glaciers et traversé
par le gang et la Yamouna doté plus
importants fleuves du pays ce petit État
himalayen de 10 millions d'habitants
semble présenter tous les atouts
nécessaires aux yeux des autorités
90 barrages sont en projet ou en
chantier et 40 sont déjà opérationnels
parmi eux le barrage de l'aguardiaci
si tu es à 400 km de celui de ta peau
vannes c'est l'un des plus récents en
activité
[Musique]
la création de l'immense réservoir d'eau
à coller à l'ouvrage a nécessité la
submersion du village de lohari
près de 100 familles ont été forcés
d'évacuer les lieux au mois d'avril 2022
dont celle de Naret showran
[Musique]
tout a été inondé
nos maisons nos arbres fruitiers les
champs que nous cultivions et où nous
faisions paître notre bétail
j'ai juste envie de pleurer quand je
vois notre village dans cet état c'est
mon lieu de naissance c'est là que j'ai
passé toute mon enfance tout n'est plus
que ruine je suis anéanti
avec très autrement de sa famille ses
ancêtres se sont établis à l'eau Harry
il y a plus d'un siècle
et voici ce qu'il reste de sa maison
nous avions trois grandes pièces ici de
ce côté notre petite échoppe à l'entrée
là-bas c'était les toilettes et la salle
de bain et notre cuisine donnée sur une
cour extérieure
tous ici et si maître des dommages
collatéraux de la politique de
développement mené par une élu
pour la production d'électricité
le gouvernement a une dette envers nous
qui avons tous sacrifié
c'est leur responsabilité de nous offrir
au moins une compensation à la hauteur
du sacrifice
à l'origine le gouvernement avait promis
d'allouer de nouvelles terres aux
habitants avant de se rétracter peu
avant la mise en service du barrage pour
protester plusieurs familles ont fait le
choix de rester dans le village elles
ont trouvé refuge dans l'ancienne école
primaire
c'est toute notre vie nous avions pour
habitude de cultiver nos propres
aliments nous n'avions pas besoin
d'aller acheter de la nourriture en
ville maintenant qui nous ont expulsés
où voulez-vous que j'aille
je n'ai plus de ferme donc plus de
revenus nous avions une si belle vie et
nous avons tout perdu
les projets hydroélectriques ne sont pas
les seuls à mettre en danger le fragile
écosystème de l'Himalaya tout au long de
notre tournage nous avons pu constater
l'étendue des projets d'infrastructures
lancés par le Premier ministre indien la
reine rameaudi en outaracan partout des
chantiers transforment la vallée 4
autoroutes et une nouvelle ligne de
chemin de fer sont en construction leur
but mieux desservir la charte d'amiatra
en français le pèlerinage des Quatre
Lieux Saints
ces nouvelles routes doivent permettre
d'attirer davantage de pèlerins vers ces
sanctuaires hindous et réduire leur
temps de transport
ces projets démesurés inquiète les
environnementsalistes de la région comme
aimant bayani
il construisent une route et là ils vont
faire un pont pour relier les deux
flancs
quelques mètres plus loin et menthe veut
nous montrer un autre chantier bien plus
important une voie ferrée est en
construction
il creuse à l'intérieur de la montagne
leur projet de ligne ferroviaire
nécessite de percer près de 100 km de
tunnel cela va causer des dommages
irréversibles irréparables en termes de
déforestation de pollution des cours
d'eau et c'est la toute première fois
que cette région va être desservie par
une ligne de train c'est une expérience
grandeur nature conduite sans avoir mené
d'expertis scientifique en amont
pour ce projet estimé à 1,4 milliards
d'euros et malgré de multiples recours
en justice le gouvernement indien a
présenté aucune étude d'impact
environnemental les 900 km d'autoroute
en construction doivent être inaugurées
en 2024 année des prochaines élections
législatives dans le pays
en bord de route et monte fait une
nouvelle découverte
ils ont creusé des trous dans ces
énormes rochers afin de les dynamiter
et tous les experts de l'Himalaya vous
diront depuis des années que tout
explosion dans le cadre de construction
doit être interdit ici
toute la vallée
avec ce projet le gouvernement indien
espère attirer jusqu'à 3 millions de
visiteurs chaque année répartis entre
les quatre sites sacrés de la région
le sanctuaire de madrina est l'un
d'entre eux
cette ville fait elle aussi l'objet d'un
vaste projet d'urbanisation affiché sur
ce panneau
ça c'est donc le schéma directeur d'une
ville nouvelle on dirait Dubaï Singapour
ou Goa et ils ont utilisé le mot
spiritualité pendant des siècles ce qui
faisait ce pèlerinage dans l'Himalaya
venait pour trouver une paix intérieure
pas pour voir ce type de construction
[Musique]
d'avril à novembre madrina s’ouvre au
touriste de tout le pays qui viennent se
recueillir au moins une fois dans leur
vie devant le temple dédié au dieu
vichenau année après année le nombre de
pèlerins a cessé d'augmenter avec le
projet d'autoroute les autorités
s'attendent à accueillir 30 000
visiteurs par jour
[Musique]
un tourisme de masse dans un
environnement géographiquement instable
un air de déjà-vu pourrait monte en 2013
à 40 km de là dans le sanctuaire de quai
d'arnat un orage suivi depuis torrentiel
à causé la mort de près de 10 000
personnes
regardez cette foule si jamais un
éboulement ou un orage violent avec une
soudaine montée des eaux se produit ce
sera le même scénario kaki d'arnaque en
2013 c'est comme si nous avions oublié
ce qui s'est passé
nous n'avons pas retenu la leçon
autant de monde ça ne peut que
surcharger ses lieux que sommes-nous en
train de faire c'est un désastre
[Musique]
l'hérissons de catastrophes dont la
région de l'Himalaya sont autant de
signaux que l'un doit prendre en compte
un équilibre indispensable à trouver
entre sa soif de développement et le
respect de l'environnement
[Musique]
et on retrouve Alban Alvarez à New Delhi
Alban depuis de nombreuses années des
experts indiens alertes sur la
vulnérabilité de l'état de
l'outarracande et depuis que vous avez
tourné ce reportage une nouvelle
catastrophe s'est produite dans la ville
de joshimat où vous avez d'ailleurs
séjourné pour ce tournage
exactement depuis le mois de décembre la
ville de joshimat subit de nombreuses
affaissements de terrain conséquences
des centaines d'habitations sont
fissurées devenu inhabitables dangereuse
et du coup des milliers de résidents du
évacués les lieux et pour à tout ça t-il
un des écologistes que nous avons
rencontré dans le cadre de ce reporter
et qui vit à Joshima s'il ne fait aucun
doute que c'est la construction du
barrage hydroélectrique non loin de
Joshima qui est la raison la cause de
ces affaissements de terrain et surtout
l'utilisation à de multiples reprises
d'explosifs en vue de construire un
tunnel sous la montagne un tunnel de
près de 12 qui 12 km alors même et bien
que de nombreux experts il y a plus de
10 ans avec clairement indiqué qu'il ne
fallait en aucun cas construire un
barrage dans cette vallée
et ces projets de centrales électriques
album ne sont pas prêtes s'arrêter dans
tout l'Himalaya
absolument il y a pas moins de 320
projets de ce type dans les tuyaux dans
tout l'Himalaya indien c'est une région
qui se tombe sur plus de 2000 km de long
et qui est fragilisé par le
réchauffement climatique vous l'avez dit
mais qui était également soumise à des
risques sismiques rendant d'autant plus
dangereux la réalisation de ce projet
mais pour le gouvernement la
construction de ces centrales
hydroélectriques mais également de ces
autoroutes et bien sont vues comme un
moyen de développer de désenclaver ces
régions mais c'est également un moyen de
mieux les contrôler de mieux les
militariser car il faut rappeler que
c'est que cette image a bien de ce que
cette Himalaya est tout simplement
partagé avec plusieurs autres pays
notamment le Pakistan et la Chine de
pays avec lesquels new des liens
entretien des relations clairement
compliquées
[Musique]